bienvenidos al espacio de historia de
france 24 mi nombre es álvaro cordero el
tiroteo masivo en una escuela primaria
de balde en texas el pasado 24 de mayo
ha vuelto a abrir el debate en torno al
control de las armas en eeuu en los
últimos años los ataques con armas de
fuego se han multiplicado en esta nación
norteamericana y aunque el debate en
torno al control armamentístico se ha
extendido los avances en esta materia
han sido muy escasos pero que hace tan
difícil poner controles en eeuu a pesar
de estas masacres la respuesta es la
segunda enmienda de la constitución
estadounidense y es que desde 1791 la
posesión de armas es un derecho
constitucional en este país un derecho
que se creó en el marco de la guerra de
independencia pero que no se ha
modificado desde entonces aunque el
contexto contemporáneo poco tenga que
ver con el que existía a finales del
siglo 18 pero más allá del contexto
histórico y su protección constitucional
es necesario destacar la facilidad con
la que en muchos estados
de comprar un arma en algunos de ellos
es solamente necesario identificarse
mostrar que no se tienen antecedentes y
mostrar un estatus migratorio y se dan
paradojas como que una persona de 18
años pueda comprar un arma
semiautomática pero no pueda tomarse una
cerveza
estas facilidades posibilitan que en
muchos estados el porcentaje de
población que posee un arma sea muy
elevado como se observa en este mapa
hasta en siete estados más del 50% de
sus habitantes tiene un arma de fuego y
en la gran mayoría de ellos más del 30
por ciento de los civiles están armados
cifras que ningún otro país del mundo ni
siquiera los que están en guerra
registra de hecho la cifra total son 300
93 millones de armas para 332 millones
de estadounidenses es decir más armas
que personas algo que ha repercutido
inevitablemente en la seguridad de esta
nación especialmente en las tres últimas
décadas los tiroteos masivos han ido en
aumento y han golpeado
indiferenciadamente a supermercados
eventos o escuelas los motivos de esos
ataques son muy variados y no responden
a un patrón concreto van desde el
supremacismo blanco a la venganza por
haber sufrido acoso escolar de todos
estos casos el que quizás sea más
emblemático es él en la escuela
secundaria de columbine en 1999 situada
en el estado de colorado aquí dos
alumnos del centro asesinaron a 13
personas con armas automáticas y
llegaron a utilizar hasta explosivos
contra compañeros y profesores la
matanza conmocionó al país y a la
opinión internacional y de hecho a día
de hoy sigue siendo una de las masacres
más recordadas
las personas están sufriendo perdidas y
debemos centrarnos en eso
pero creo que en las próximas semanas
debemos analizarlo y ver si podemos
aprender algo y ver qué podemos hacer
para evitar más pérdidas
[Música]
pero las promesas de cambio quedaron en
poco aunque durante la etapa de bill
clinton se reguló el acceso a armas
automáticas tras la llegada al poder de
george w.bush esta norma fue eliminada y
los tiroteos masivos siguieron
aumentando masacres como las de virginia
tech en 2007 binghampton en 2009 sandy
hook en 2012 o las vegas' en 2017
conmocionaron de forma cada vez más
habitual a eeuu hasta el punto que una
buena parte del partido demócrata
comenzó a calificar estos tiroteos como
una epidemia
entonces
esta epidemia de violencia armada no
conoce fronteras no conoce límites de
ningún tipo y no es la única
y cuando esto sucede las personas se
apresuran a decir que ofrecen sus
pensamientos y oraciones pero eso no es
suficiente cuántas personas tienen que
morir antes de que realmente actuemos
américa
efe pero siguió sin haber cambios la
presión que ejerce sobre la política
estadounidense la industria
armamentística o lobbies como la
asociación nacional del rifle es muy
fuerte estos grupos de poder defienden a
ultranza el derecho a llevar armas y se
niegan a que exista cualquier tipo de
control a pesar de la creciente
tendencia de los tiroteos masivos en la
nación gran parte de su fuerza se debe
al apoyo del partido republicano y esta
cuestión ha sido la causa de un
enfrentamiento constante entre este
partido y el demócrata el ejemplo más
claro lo encontramos en posturas como la
de donald trump que días después de la
masacre de walt de defendió el uso de
armas en profesores
como parte de un plan integral de
seguridad escolar es hora de permitir
que los maestros altamente capacitados
lleven armas ocultas de manera segura y
discreción a los deberes del saint
porque no hay lugar más atractivo para
un asesino en masa que nacional que
declaración al libre de armas gana frei
esos son los lugares más peligrosos
yourspace pero en realidad estas
políticas han contribuido al aumento de
tiroteos masivos desde el año 2018 hasta
llegar a un máximo de 691 en el año 2021
datos que a pesar de ser demoledores no
parece que vayan a significar un cambio
a pesar de que existan ejemplos
positivos como el de reino unido que
tras regular el uso de armas en 1996 vio
como los tiroteos descendieron de hecho
la dinámica va al contrario el número de
ventas en los últimos años se ha
disparado y sin un consenso entre el
partido demócrata y el republicano sobre
esta cuestión parece muy complicado que
se legisla algo que pueda cambiar la
normativa actual una situación que
probablemente y seguirá golpeando a eeuu
en el futuro con esto concluimos gracias
por compartir y comentar estas historias
que las encuentran en los programas de
france 24 punto com
[Música]